nos preguntan cuál de los siguientes
sectores tienen la misma componente ya
que el vector a selecciona todas las que
apliquen y bueno por aquí tengo al
vector am el cual es el vector que me
importa me voy a fijar en este vector am
y me voy a fijar en su componente james
porque es lo que nos piden cuál de los
siguientes vectores tienen la misma
componente y que el vector a así que
para fijarnos en la componente jet del
vector a me voy a parar en su punto
inicial y en este punto inicial tengo el
valor de jeff igual a cero entonces voy
a ir desde este valor de james igual a
cero déjame ponerlo con este color desde
igual a cero voy a subir hasta el valor
de 10 igual a 3 que es donde está el
punto final así que puedo decir que el
cambio en 10 va a ser de 0 a 3 ni cambio
en james va a ser de 0 a 3 lo cual me da
tres unidades positivas porque voy hacia
arriba o podemos decir también que la
componente vale 3
dicho de otra manera podemos ver a este
vector am al vector a lo podemos
escribir mediante sus componentes y
bueno sus componentes son bueno
realmente no nos interesa mucho su
componente x este vector a porque nos
piden la componente y la componente i
pero si nos fijamos aquí podemos ver que
la componente x en este caso va de menos
2 a 4 lo cual es 66 y la que sí nos
interesa es la componente bien la cual
toma el valor de 13 por lo tanto este
vector
lo podemos ver como sus componentes que
son 6 3 y la que nos interesa es la
componente y bien pues ahora fijémonos
en qué otro vector tiene una componente
de 3 y para eso vamos a fijarnos primero
en este vector b lo que buscamos es
tener una componente de 3 es decir vamos
a subir 3 unidades desde el punto
inicial hasta el punto final si nos
fijamos aquí en la componente 10 de este
vector b quien va a ser bueno pues este
su punto inicial
hasta acá lo que estamos haciendo es
bajar tres unidad
pero ojo en este caso estamos bajando
tres unidades por lo tanto esta
componente va a ser igual a menos tres
su componente james va a ser igual a
menos tres así que su componente ya no
es la misma así que vamos a escribir
este vector ver este vector b se va a
ver más o menos así algo en x menos 3 y
si observas menos 3 no es lo mismo que 3
y por lo tanto no es un vector que tenga
la misma componente y ok vamos a ver el
siguiente así que pensemos en el vector
c
bueno pues fijémonos en la componente
del vector sen y para eso observa que
aquí en su punto inicial y vamos a bajar
hasta acá vamos a bajar a 123 unidades
por lo tanto la componente i del vector
se es menos 3 y puedes estar tentado en
decir que si es la misma pero este tiene
el valor de 3 positivo y este el valor
de menos 3
así que el vector se lo podemos ver como
algo coma menos 3 y de igual manera no
tiene la misma componente que nosotros
buscamos bien y que es el vector de
bueno pues el vector de vamos a fijarnos
en su componente y este su punto inicial
y vamos a subir hasta este punto final y
bueno subimos a si te das cuenta vamos a
subir una dos tres unidades
por lo tanto delta de james es igual a
tres o dicho otra manera su componente
ya es igual a tres observa que empezamos
en el valor de cinco y llegamos al valor
de ocho y por lo tanto tenemos una
componente de tres dicho de otra manera
este vector de se va a ver más o menos
así va a ser igual a algo coma tres y en
este caso si tenemos la misma componente
james por lo tanto puedo decir que el
vector de es nuestra respuesta correcta
y ya está con esto hemos resuelto este